what you got here are two foci right and
if I want to model for myself with my
blanket hooters if i were to monitor for
myself a series of points where if you
add up the distance from here to here
you'll get a constant here's my husband
the length of my street okay let's call
this eight units or I have no families
okay and do you agree for instance i'm
just going to start really really slow
right do you agree that for instance
that point right this is actually time
coming that point there right i'm going
to even do some solid line to you I put
it there and then we gonna come another
this point over here do you agree right
that those two points have they exhibit
this property right if I add them up the
sum of those two legs is just it's just
what this string is around moving it
around okay so i tried to practice but i
still find quite hard let's see what
happens if we trace out the locus of
those points right so I'm Scott from a
star from you
I got pretty close you get the idea the
siphon conclusion bring string and we
talked to Nathan's yeah I even having so
much trouble drawing ellipses why not
you know what have we just established
okay we have shown that we started with
how we have ish stuck with the equation
of the ellipse we started the parabola
and then we said let's muck around with
the proportions the eccentricity right
so in other words we had not just PS
envy but we also had pd we coach the
algebra and out popped out the equation
this is a whole different way of doing
things right and this by the way is what
makes the Whispering Gallery work does
that make sense right the reason why if
you're standing here and you whisper to
the person standing here the reason that
it works is because all of the sound
waves that are coming from you are going
to travel the exact same distance no
matter where they bounce on the walls on
an archway of the Whispering Gallery
right so being that they travel the same
distance the sounds arrive at the same
time right at the same instance because
in that space sounds going to travel up
that right and so they arrive at you
rather than scramble which is what
everyone in here here right they will
hear exactly crystal clear even if
you'll respond okay so therefore now we
can make a heading what are we just
established okay what this is is an
alternative locus definition
for the ellipse it is a whole different
way of arriving at the equation over the
lips and at noticing one of its most
critical properties now I want you to
pause and we did all of this through
like proper actual numbers right I said
that it would be substantially dealer
you really actually do need to do this
algebraically because then you will see
that this eight is not a coincidence
right it's not just a train away now if
you look carefully you might get with
yes at what a is and what connection has
to the number that I've got here now if
you could really really intuitive do
suggest a right this is for square and
this is nine which is three squared and
now what is it that the foursquare comes
into play why is it before is what ends
up coming up my factorization of me hey
very good it's all about the major axis
right you've got your way in this case
we didn't deal with the directrix but
it's still the same thing I've got plus
or minus a equal to 0 right as you see
the major axis is where all the action
is happening okay so this guy in fact
here is not just a bike for instance is
in fact 2a and that is an important
results prove now I'm going to come
around to you guys shortly because this
is all numbers right a lot of stuff
simplified out that when it's algebra
doesn't simplify a [ __ ] terms and then
go they don't call this they're not like
terms you have to do a lot of massaging
of the terms and your proof ends up
about about that long now that doesn't
look too long but a lot of the steps and
i like i'm going to show you this in a
second a lot of the steps like why would
you do that like how on earth did you
know to do that like what made you do
that particular algebraic simplification
and the answer is when mathematicians go
three until I come back knee it must be
a patented here then when you go to the
abstract algebra you let the camp
searching for something a lot to be
simplification like at random I'm after
something
it so that guides the prison's just like
a treat identity when you saw him ok so
I'll come around and show that to you
but this property here let's put a box
around penis ok it is oft-forgotten
because people focus on the other lochus
definition for the lips the main one but
this is that I hope you can see it is
beautifully simple right until you
therefore can get lots of geometric
insights out of it because of how easy
it is right some of the questions in 4.1
all right now like I said that's all of
the basic stuff around lips today we
will revisit the ellipse and we have a
look at we go ahead we know you can
probably guess at this right if i give
you the unit circle right I can stay any
point on the circumference in Cartesian
terms so business the unit circle what's
the equation tentative good so it
continued in terms i would state this as
X comma plus or minus the square root of
1 minus y square and the plus or minus
depends on whether I'm on the top
semicircle or the bottom right sets in
Qatar you x but of course we know of the
only way you can do it how else would
you do it yeah we used cars and side so
that is the way we weep amateur could
express it we can do the same thing for
the ellipse in fact because their lives
in the circle so closely related they're
warmer side it ok we will come back to
that a bit later on we're a bit further
into clinics but for now gray which is
done